where
does the value of money come from like
where is it actually
where is it so it's a sheet of paper or
it's coins
but
it feels like in a platonic sense
there's some kind of thing that's
actually storing the value as us a bunch
of ants are dancing around and so on
i come from a family of physicists i'm
the black sheep of the family my
mother's a physicist my sister is
and uh so when you ask me to explain
something in in physics terms i
i get a kind of little part of me dies
because i know i'll fail
but in in truth it doesn't really matter
what we decide
money is going to be and anything
can
record
uh crystallize the the relationship
between the the creditor and the debtor
it could be a piece of paper it can be a
piece of metal it can be nothing can
just be a digital entry
it's
trust that we're really
talking about here
we are
not just trusting one another we may not
but we are trusting
the money
so
whatever we use to represent
the creditor debtor relationship whether
it's a bank note or a coin or whatever
it does depend on
us both trusting it
and that doesn't always pertain
what we see in episodes of inflation
especially episodes of hyperinflation is
a crisis of trust a crisis of confidence
in
the means of payment
and this is very traumatic for the
societies to which it happens
by and large human beings particularly
once you have a rule of law
uh system of the sort that evolved in
the west and then became generalized
are predisposed to trust one another
and the default setting is to trust
money even when it depreciates a quite
steady rate as
the us dollar has done
pretty much uninterruptedly since
the 1960s
it takes quite a big disruption for
money to lose that trust but i think
essentially what money should be thought
of as
is a series of tokens that can take any
form we like and can be purely digital
which represent our transactions as as
creditors and debtors
and the whole thing depends on our
collective trust to work
i had to explain this to stephen colbert
once and the
call burster the old old shirt that was
actually funny and
great
when he said um
so so so neil could i be money and i
said yes you know we could
we could settle
a debt with a human being that was quite
common
in much of history but but it's not the
most convenient
form of money
money has to be convenient that's why
when they worked out how to make
payments with cell phones the chinese
simply went straight there from bank
accounts they skipped out credit cards
you won't see credit cards in china
except in the hands of naive tourists
you